- I want to react to one
specific thing you said
about the angry men.
It is 100% projection.
The angry young men and
women are on the left.
How could they not be?
You're living in a racist,
sexist, misogynist,
homophobic, xenophobic society.
You are a victim.
Unless you are a white, heterosexual,
Christian male, you are a victim.
Who is producing anger, us?
Saying, you know what?
Life is inherently difficult.
Now what do you do?
Make your bed.
Start with that.
(calm music)
Hi everybody, I'm Dennis Prager,
and Dave says I don't need an introduction
which is a very major compliment.
I'm not sure it's true, but,
well, it doesn't matter.
You're here.
You're here because of Dave Rubin anyway.
So we're gonna talk about
"Don't Burn This Book" chapter nine.
I am very delighted that David asked me
to comment on chapter nine.
It's find a mentor.
It's largely about Jordan Peterson,
but of course it's even larger than,
by the way, let me interrupt myself.
I think that Jordan Peterson,
I wrote the introduction
to his biography, I think that he is one
of the most wonderful human
beings that I have met
in my life and I cannot tell you
how many wonderful people I have met.
This is an extraordinary
human being in every way,
and like many extraordinary
people, he bears the weight
of the world on his shoulders
because he's so sensitive
to the pain of the world
and he wants to try
and make a dent in this
tremendous amount of pain.
I have often said on my radio show that
if pain were water, the world would drown.
So I resonate to him
tremendously and you, Dave,
obviously do and what your
chapter, while it's mostly
about Jordan, is about the
subject of finding a mentor.
So let me tell you something you'll find,
I think, of interest.
I don't know, I've been
broadcasting 35 years,
so I started in my 30s, and
so I was a kid when I started
and I'm not a kid now.
So gradually over the course of time,
more and more people would
say, calling into the show,
Dennis, I just want you to know
you're like a father to me,
and I've always answered,
good, everyone needs one,
and I've said all the time
it is every male's task
to become a father figure to younger men.
That is our task, and that
is why every human being,
and I'll talk about men now,
every man can make a difference
whether you have children or not.
Whatever your circumstance,
if you are a father figure
to one younger man, the younger
man may be 10 years younger
than you, you have made
a dent in this world,
but a lot of men, like a lot of women,
don't want to grow up.
So the last thing they want
to be is a father figure to anybody.
They want to be the
peer of younger people,
not the father figure of younger people.
So I can't tell you how much
I resonate to that chapter,
even the part about dressing
formally just as you are now.
I mean, it's dramatic.
- This is my favorite black
shirt, come on, Prager.
- I'm sure it is.
- You are definitely dressing
appropriately for the chapter.
You know, a few things that
you said there really strike me
as interesting because, you
know, one of the main things
that we heard throughout the tour
as the hit pieces would
come out in the media is
that the only people who show
up to these Jordan Peterson
events are angry young
men, and it was interesting
because not only was
that factually not true,
it was usually about
60, 40 male to female,
but they weren't angry
as far as I could tell.
It was a lot of people that
were trying to fix their lives
and they were, of course, every age,
and there were literally
grandmother groups that showed up
and their were trans
people there and everything
that there could possibly
be, but this idea
that he was only talking to
angry young men I thought
was sort of fascinating
because if it was true,
let's just pretend for a second that
what they were saying was
true, well, if you're talking
to angry young men and you're
making their lives better,
helping them get away from anger, well,
would that not be considered good?
But I know the media is sort of unable
to deal with somewhat complex topics.
So to see that and then
to see that, you're right,
there has been some weird
shift that I think you have
because of radio and
because of being public
about your opinions for so
long, you've definitely seen
where something happened that
is not just specific to men,
but perhaps has more to do with young men
where the father figure or
the trusted uncle or someone
that would give them guidance on really
what the hard things are in the world,
to really be responsible about your life,
and just because you don't like your job,
it doesn't mean you can quit it tomorrow
if you've got family to feed,
and just really, what does he say?
I mean, simple stuff.
Clean your room before
you clean the world.
Stand up straight with
your shoulders back.
Like these messages, he
would say it sometimes
during the tour.
He would say, some of my
messages are not rocket science,
but they're long-forgotten
truths, and I think you're a guy
that's been trying to fight
for long-forgotten truths
for a long time.
- Yes, I mean look, there's
so many things you said
that I would love to react to.
We are on this world, on this planet
for a limited period of
time, and you have to decide
what you want to do with your life.
I want to touch people
to lead a better life.
In this terms, better
meaning deeper and more good,
but I want to react to one
specific thing you said
about the angry men.
It is 100% projection.
The angry young men and
women are on the left.
How could they not be?
You're living in a racist,
sexist, misogynist,
homophobic, xenophobic society.
You are a victim.
Unless you are a white, heterosexual,
Christian male, you are a victim.
Who is producing anger, us?
Saying, you know what?
Life is inherently difficult.
Now what do you do?
Make your bed, start with that.
We are, I wrote a book on happiness.
That's not exactly an anger-inducing book.
I've had Happiness Hour
on my show for 21 years.
They create anger.
We're trying to subdue it and make happy,
better, richer people.
Now, I don't mean richer
in money, richer in life.
- I wonder, Dennis, do you think
that everyone actually needs a mentor?
Because one of the
things that I talk about
in the chapter is that it's
not that Jordan and I sat down,
it's not that he sat me
down and said, hey Dave,
we're going on tour and I'm
gonna impart some wisdom on you.
It wasn't some sort of Jedi
sit down kind of thing.
It really was that through the year
and a half we spent together,
I saw him doing the best
that he could and I saw
him sometimes admitting
what his shortcomings were.
I saw him sometimes in
front of 5,000 people.
If a pointy, you know, a
specifically pointed question
was asked about something,
if people asked, for example,
about his carnivore diet and
they would ask for advice
about their diet, he would
say, well, I'm not a dietician.
I'm not a nutritionist.
I can tell you what works for me,
and I think hearing
somebody with some humility
and more than anything else
try to put truth in the world,
I think I got that by osmosis,
but it wasn't really a sit down.
I almost didn't realize that
I needed it until I got it.
Does that make sense?
- Totally, totally, but your
opening question is a variant.
Does everyone need a mentor?
The answer is yes, absolutely,
but the mentor can come
in different shapes, forms, and ways.
So I believe my father
was not a loving father,
but he was a mentor which
frankly is more important.
I will give up 1,000 hugs
for 1,000 sources of wisdom.
No, for 10 wisdoms, okay?
I would like both, but
if I have to choose,
there's no question in my mind.
So in my early life, and
I had him as a model.
That I did, he was.
He was a model of a man
and boys need male models.
Number two, I had mentors
from 3,500 years ago.
I'm a religious Jew.
I've written a bible commentary,
"The Rational Bible,"
and the figures there, Moses was a mentor.
I know that to many of
your secular viewers,
this sounds almost maybe silly even
or certainly odd, but it's true.
I studied this man all of
my life and he has flaws.
That's the beauty of the
Old Testament figures.
They're flawed.
So I can't relate to a perfect
person, but I can relate
to a flawed man who does great things.
So historical figures,
a Churchill, mentors,
I'll give you one more example.
My dearest friend, doctor Stephen
Marmer, is a psychiatrist.
He tells the story of a
patient from many years ago.
His father was a traveling salesman.
Came home only on weekends.
So he'd spend the whole
time with his wife.
He wanted to reconnect with
his wife on the weekend.
He didn't have time for his kids.
So what did the son do?
He went to the movies.
In those days, the figures
in movies were male mentors.
He got to be a man from the movies.
That's not available today.
The men in movies are largely children.
- There's so much there because it's like,
I think people are seeing that
they're missing something,
and in many ways it's why PragerU works,
it's why Shapiro's message gets across.
It's that something got lost in the last,
I suspect you'd think it's
longer than I would think,
but I would say in the
last two decades maybe,
but particularly in the last decade
where everybody just thought, whatever,
life is just whatever you
want at any given moment
and if you grab it, you grab it, great,
and you just keep going, where
now there is some other thing
that's working for people.
So I suspect that when
you read the chapter,
when I talk about finding the
importance of biblical stories
and as you know, we're
expanding our family here,
and those are messages that I
kept getting through Jordan.
You know, he said something
that's a little counter
to what you said before,
but not that far off.
I would hear him say something
like, for almost everybody,
being a parent is a crucial part of life.
Not for everybody, but
for almost everybody,
and what I kept thinking around
that, you know my husband,
David, you and Sue have
been here for dinner.
I knew that David wanted kids
and I didn't particularly
want them because I had
put so much investment--
- So you married up, man, you married up.
- But I did marry up, that is for sure,
and you've had the chicken.
You said it was the best
chicken you ever had,
but I thought as I
heard Jordan saying that
that I started thinking, well,
could I be the exception to the rule?
Could I be the exception of the person
that could not have kids
and feel fully realized?
And then on top of that
fact, well then, what would
that make me to the person
I married if I'm not going
to allow that person to feel
fully fulfilled in their life?
So he moved me.
In many ways, it was almost
accidental because again,
he wasn't sending these messages to me,
but they were messages through osmosis.
- The problem with what you're
saying, oh, and I 100% agree
with it, but the problem
with what you're saying
to vast numbers of young
people now is the idea
of growing up is just not a value.
It's not thought of.
When I was a kid, again, in
a religious Jewish setting,
all I was told is be a
mench which is a man,
and I mean, what did a man mean?
A man means you grow up and
you take responsibility.
You'll find this interesting.
On my male female hour,
I ask women, just women,
call in for the next hour, what
do you define as masculine?
And do you know, I did not
know what they would say.
Overwhelmingly, they said
the sexiest man is the man
who takes responsibility.
- It doesn't surprise me.
It really doesn't surprise
- No, I'm sure it doesn't.
- me actually.
- Yes.
So I knew, I knew from the earliest age,
I have to get married, I have
to have children, have to.
It's not a matter of, gee, do I want to?
No, no, Dennis, you want to
grow up, this is what you do.
- So one of the things
that we've talked about
and I've had you on the show
obviously a couple times
and I've once had you in
here to debate morality
with Michael Shermer who comes
from a nonbeliever perspective,
but in the few pages
that I was writing about
the biblical stories
and how I have come to believe
that we need these eternal
truths to organize a society,
I suspect you were probably,
you know, you must have had
a little smile on your face
reading that, but do you agree
with my premise that on the micro-level
that individually you
could be a nonbeliever
and be purely moral and good
and all of those things?
Because my argument is not that
you can't do it personally.
I think it's very hard and
I think most people can't.
I had John Kasich in here once
and he said something sort
of off the cuff that I ended up thinking
was really quite profound.
He said, you know, a lot of
people could do it without God,
I'm just not one of those people.
I thought that was actually
a pretty moving statement,
and I think I've come around
to a belief that's very similar
to that, but I do believe that
individually people can do it
without God or without a set
of rules outside of themselves,
but that a society simply
cannot organize itself
without it and--
- That's exactly it.
So it's like society needs
people to wear seat belts.
Does every individual
need to wear a seat belt?
No, but society needs to wear a seat belt.
Religion is a seat belt, and by the way,
of course there were atheists
and there were good secular people.
It's not debatable, but
there were good people
who believed in Zeus.
There were good people
who worshiped 406 Gods.
So therefore, what?
It doesn't prove anything.
Yes, the conscience is
universal, but it's not enough.
I give the example, you
want me to say it or
do you just want
- Yeah go ahead.
- To say something?
Okay, so I opened up my
book "The Rational Bible."
It's now two of five
volumes, Genesis and Exodus,
and I tell the story.
I had a difficult time with
my parents in my late teens
and my early 20s which is hardly shocking.
Okay, but I treated them with
respect every day of my life,
no matter how difficult
my relationship was,
and there was only one reason, only one.
I believe that God had
instructed me honor your father
and your mother, period.
Afterwards, I did it because I loved them,
but when I didn't love
them, I still did it
because there was a God
who told me to do so.
- Yeah, I mean I think that
really is the undergirding point
that I'm talking about.
The thing outside of us
that can help organize us.
So one other thing on
Jordan before we finish up.
I obviously in the book, I
finished writing the book
in July, we're now in May.
So you know, it takes quite some time
to get these things actually out there,
and it was a little unclear
exactly what was going on
with Jordan when I was writing it.
I have seen him since and
as I keep telling everybody,
I can't say anything
that's not fully public,
but he is getting better and all that,
but I'm wondering did you ever
see or have callers told you
about moments when someone
that they really believed
in suddenly had a tumble like that?
And you know, and I do
want to add one other thing
about this that he was
very upfront and would talk
about it often that he
was taking a small amount
of medication for anti-anxiety,
and then as you know,
his wife was diagnosed
with terminal cancer.
They thought that was the end for her.
I was literally at lunch with him
when he got the call about that.
On top of the fame, the
hatred, the hit pieces,
the love, the travel, I
mean, just everything,
and of course this is for a guy
that was a clinical psychologist,
not somebody who thought he was gonna be
the leading intellectual in
the world, but I'm curious
if you have any experience
in that sort of thing?
When people look up to
somebody and it's like none
of us are, if I can say
Jesus to a devout Jew,
it's like a certain amount
of people probably thought
he was Jesus, like some other
thing is really what I mean,
like almost not human, and
yet none of us are that.
- I have discussed this
on my show all of my life.
I've actually read on the
air letters like this.
Dear Dennis--
- We've got a minute,
Dennis, bring us home here.
- Okay, yep, I'll get it done in a minute.
Dear Dennis, I want you
to know I have admired you
for 25 years and I heard
you say that X, Y, or Z,
and I realized you're a
fraud, and I would write back
and say, so how did I
fool you for 25 years?
This is a danger that people have.
There is no perfect being,
and by the way, why is he less perfect
because he takes an anti-anxiety pill?
It's such a bizarre thing.
It's not even a flaw.
It's not like, you know, he
was caught having an affair,
and even then I would still
say, okay, humans are weak.
- I would still think he's one
of the greatest people I knew
but this isn't even a flaw.
He's taking care of himself.
He deserves to take care of himself.
You'll never admire anyone
if they have to be perfect.
- Yeah, that's why they
say don't meet your heroes.
I think that's usually what
they're trying to tell you.
Well, with that in mind, even
though I wrote Jordan Peterson
as the mentor, I do include
you in that group of people
who have helped me clean up
my life and clean up sort
of everything that I'm doing
here, and I look forward
to having you and Sue over
for dinner again soon,
and then when we post a picture
about it, people will say
that you're a homophobe
and I'm a self-hating gay
and you know, the usual, the usual stuff,
but we know the truth
- But that's proof.
That's proof, but get a bigger menorah.
- I know, you want a bigger, all right,
I've gotta work on the menorah.
I'm sure you know a guy.
Thanks, Prager.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead
of nonstop yelling, check
out our politics playlist,
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety
of topics, watch our full
episode playlist all right
over here, and to get
notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.